the thing that's always a big mistake is
going after a giant market on on day one
because that's typically evidence that
that you somehow haven't defined the
categories correctly that and it's it
normally means that there's going to be
too much competition in one way or
another and so I think almost all the
successful companies uh in Silicon
Valley had some model of starting with
small markets and expanding and you know
if you take Amazon you start with you
start with you know just a bookstore we
have all the books in the world so it's
it's a it's a it's a better bookstore
than anybody else has in the world when
it starts in the 90s it's online there's
things you can do you can't do before
and then you gradually expand into all
sorts of different forms of e-commerce
and other things beyond that
um you know eBay you start with Pez
dispensers you move on to beanie babies
and eventually uh it's it's all these
different
um auctions for all these sorts of
different Goods
um and uh and what was very
counterintuitive about what's very
counterintuitive about many of these
companies is they often start with
markets that are so small that people
don't think
um they don't think that they're
valuable at all when when you get
started
um the the PayPal version of this was uh
was when we started with uh with power
sellers on eBay which was about 20 000
people when we first saw this happening
in December of 99 January 2000 right
after we launched uh there was a sense
that uh that these were all um it was
such a small Market it was terrible we
thought these were terrible customers to
have it's just people selling junk on
the internet why in the world do we want
to be going after this Market but um but
you you know you there was a way to get
a product that was much better for
everybody in that market you could um
and we got to something like 25 30 you
know Market penetration in two or three
months and you've got some walking you
got brand recognition and you're able to
to build the business from there so um
so I always think these um these these
very small markets are are quite
underrated uh the Facebook version of
this I always give is that uh you know
the initial Market at Facebook was 10
000 people at Harvard it went from zero
to sixty percent market share in 10 days
that was a very auspicious start
um the way this gets analyzed in
Business Schools is always
um that's ridiculous it's such a small
Market it can't have any value at all
and so I think the business school
analysis of Facebook early on or of uh
PayPal early on or of eBay early on is
that the markets were perhaps so small
as to have uh almost no value and they
would have had little value had they
stayed small but it turned out there
were ways to then grow them
concentrically and that's what made them
uh that's what made them so valuable and
so
you want to be you know you want to be a
one-of-a-kind company where it's the
only one in a small ecosystem you don't
want to be the fourth online pet food
company you don't want to be the 10th a
thin film solar panel company you don't
want to be the 100th restaurant in Palo
Alto
um your restaurant industry is a
trillion dollar industry so if you do a
market size analysis you'd include
restaurants are a fantastic business to
go into and it's often large markets
large existing markets typically mean
that you have uh tons of competition
very very hard to uh to differentiate so
the first very counter-intuitive
into our idea is is to go after small
markets often markets that are so small
people don't even notice them they don't
think that they make sense that's where
you've got to put hold and then um and
then if those markets are able to expand
you can uh scale into a a big Monopoly
business
the second thing that's really important
is that whatever idea you come up with
in your Ivory Tower
is not going to work okay because you
come up with something in your head
which you think okay there's this
offering Gap I can go and I can do it
and what will happen is that when you go
talk to customers they'll say no I don't
I don't need this right but the
important thing that you have to do is
that you have to really really pay
attention
to what your customers telling you so
what will happen is in the conversation
that you're having they might make a
passing remark I don't need this but if
you had something like this I would be
interested
when they say something like that what
you got to do is drop your stupid idea
and go all in on what they're saying
because they are going to tell you what
the real offering Gap is whatever you
came up with is useless and doesn't
exist what One customer tells you
is this pure gold
so
I'll give you an example I remember
there's a there's a really good friend
of mine in Chicago
is this kind of Maverick kind of
computer geek and uh he had done a lot
of different kind of software tools and
different he was like 19 or 20 years old
and he was going to the software tools
trade show to show off all his different
tools he had built like you know he was
trying to do like Google Maps
25 years ago you know the Computing
couldn't handle it 30 years ago like it
was going to fail you know so but but he
had all these ideas about different
things he wanted to do so he's making
kind of the background for his booth and
he had these seven tools he wanted to
talk about so it was like four on one
side four bullets and then three on the
other side it wasn't matching so he
wanted like eight bullets instead of
seven bullets and so he comes up with a
fictional product which doesn't exist
and he makes that the eighth bullet okay
and then two days in the trade show no
one has any interest in any of his
bullets okay this one guy who's got a
booth across the aisle from him has
spent two days looking at those eight
bullets okay and after two days just
before he's like wrapping up he comes
across the aisle to talk to him he said
I wanna I want that eighth bullet
product okay
so virish said okay
I can get it to you in about six weeks
or like you know I can I can do it sure
it turns out the eighth bullet became
install Shield
okay the tool we all use to install
anything on Windows right so vireish
basically created install Shield because
the guy across the aisle came to him and
says I need that install tool to install
my software so that's what I want and so
he goes back
he creates install shield for this one
customer
and then he realizes no one has any
interest in any other nonsense he's
working on and then he goes all in on
install Shield
and virish is now you know walked off
into the sunset
doing just great doing just fine I think
he was he was retired in his 30s part of
computer folklore you know great worked
out great so I think the the really
important thing is that your customer
will always tell you
they'll tell you what you need to do
what happens with most of us is we are
too headstrong to listen you you have to
sometimes it'll just be a passing remark
you know because they're not trying to
tell you listen build this or do this
they'll I wish I had this or something
like that will come up in conversation
and you have to really pay attention and
I think that's really important because
it's really difficult as an entrepreneur
without having all the market know-how
to really understand what is going on
a friend of mine who like me was a
Trader he was a former partner at
Goldman Sachs an oil Trader so he talks
like all Traders it got in a very bad
idea
to invest in a restaurant business and
if I have one piece of advice in case I
die here just don't invest in a
restaurant don't open a restaurant okay
unless you really uh want to lose your
money slowly all right or
or sometimes quickly in New York city so
he discovered the following that uh
the restaurant business has a lot of
prizes
the best sushi in Lower Manhattan the
best sushi you know was music versus
whatever so you have all these
categories okay and then there is a best
restaurant in that category all right
the best rare steak the best
T-Bone whatever west of the Hudson you
have all these categories and their
prices actually now who decide on these
prices
journalists and other restaurant owners
there is a Gala dinner
where they give these prices and guess
what
most restaurants have got prizes
were closed we're shut down all right so
we're shuttled down no you know out of
business okay so it tells you the
following
any business where you're judged by your
peers and not by some contact with
reality
is gonna rot
eventually all right that's why
companies go bust that's what happens
now the this person I think is a plumber
right
are plumbers judged by other plumbers or
the judge by
okay they're just by other problems no
uh no it's just by you you're a client
okay very good so if you you know they
may love you other plumbers but that's
it so any business that where you have
contact with reality in the form of your
clients judging you
okay has fewer experts What I Call
Expert problem which I outlined in the
Black Swan
the next mistake of entrepreneurs is
they believe that they should do things
serially which is to do things one at a
time first you raise money
then you build a team
then you write the software
then you ship then you collect okay
that's a Serial world the serial world
and Entrepreneurship does not exist
unfair as it may seem if you are an
entrepreneur you are going to have to be
raising money
writing software
prototyping selling recruiting and
collecting money all at the same time it
is all these paths moving down the road
at the same time it is not a Serial
process it is a parallel process you
need to understand that's how the world
works that it is all about moving
multiple things down the road in a
perfect world I grant you it would be
nice if all you could do was focus on
money and then all you had to do is
focus on hiring and then all you had to
do is focus on programming and then all
you have to do is focus on selling and
then all you had to do is focus on
collecting that is not the real world
the real world is you have to do all
that at once
all three of us up here are tinkerers
like I you know was early on tinkering
with Twitter for philosophy
um you know you sahil you're tinkering
with gumroad and like the weird way that
you run it uh you're tinkering on the
crowdfunding side you were tinkering on
rolling funds I was tinkering on how to
mechanize Angel Investing in VC I was
kind of opening things up with the blogs
on Venture hacks and that was tinkering
Ben you were tinkering on strategory and
dithering like we're tinkerers right and
I think most successful creators are
ultimately tinkerers through just sort
of playing around at the edges of their
field on something that is interesting
to them it's not really with some strong
motive it's play it's not really with a
motive to like create something great
out of it because they're they're
genuinely interested and most tinkering
is wasted it's like when your kids were
playing most that time is you know quote
unquote wasted but once in a while it
will result in something which for a
child might be a hobby and for an adult
it might be a vocation yeah I think it's
also inherently low status right I think
you you kind of spend years not making
any money and maybe not billing an
audience and getting really good at a
skill but you don't have any any way to
know if you know if that's actually
going to turn into anything uh that's
sort of turning into something is you
know kind of happens all at once 10
years later
well I think there's something too about
learning how to be in your particular
moment and people get so fixed well five
ten years in the future particularly
when it comes to the career and the real
danger is you end up like succeeding and
then you ended up in a place that's just
not very relevant or interesting or
there's a ton of competition and I look
back like how I ended up what I'm doing
and
God said they had the quote you know you
look backwards and you connect the docs
warning I was you know maximizing
whatever I was doing at that particular
time that's what pays off and you see so
many people get so distracted about
where they want to go and they don't
take full advantage of the spot that
they're in and then you look back I was
like man I wish I would have spent that
time better because I could have really
used that experience and it's already
too late
you certainly don't want to plan for
trying to predict too much in the future
like I think the worst title you can
possibly have in your bios futurist
first of all it's just tone deaf but
when someone says futurist and it's like
ah you know they're trying too hard
they're trying too hard to live in the
future when yes you're right your only
moment of power and knowledge is a
present you just act from the present
it's not to say you shouldn't have like
goals and plans and those kinds of
things it's kind of nice to have them
loosely held but if you stick too
closely to them you'll miss reality
reality is very fluid and very complex
and it's much more about navigating from
the small set of options presented to
you much more Choose Your Own Adventure
style than you know top and down Soviet
style planning with five-year plans and
I'm gonna get to Aid and B and C you
know I think the other thing with that
too you do need a long-term goal but
that gives you a way to think about the
immediate term options right like so I
have three options today that are not my
long-term goal I know the general
direction I'm going so I can choose this
one that maybe is sub-optimal or maybe
it seems further but I'm building up a
particular skill or getting a particular
sort of experience that will get me
closer to that long-term goal without
having yeah like a five-year plan I
think that's the exact like the exact
wrong way to go about it
well I think it's it's what's so
difficult when you when someone asks
someone who's successful like why did
you become successful and it basically
forces I feel like the person to lie
because you you look back connect the
dots and then you can't help but sort of
believe that it was it sort of happened
on purpose and that you sort of had you
know you can't remember what it was like
to not know where you were going
yeah first I picked sperm number three
billion 768 412 that then routed its way
to egg number 14 on the exact date of
blah blah blah so what is audience oh
sorry
oh no I I was funny I told the story on
this week's export exactly where it's
hilarious that I'm known as the
newsletter guy
it was a total accident where I had I
had the vision to have a subscription
based one was all website Centric and it
was a total disaster and I I actually
watched it on Thursday
it was a total mess I tore it out over
the weekend I told people like look guys
just screwed up the website style for
anyone that's not a subscriber I it's
the wrong direction I'm just gonna email
you if you subscribe I'll email you
additional stuff in addition to the
website
it's like literally like a spur of the
moment I have to fix this problem figure
it out how am I going to get content to
my subscribers without having a bad
experience or not on subscribers and
then now today I'm the newsletter guy
it's like so there when you look
backwards if you're actually honest
about it there's a lot of luck for
certain a lot of like just in the right
way to take the right choice it's funny
Angelus has a similar story because uh
first there was a network for sharing
deal flow that nivi and I built or
mostly nivi built called the pound deal
flow Network it's literally a little
social network with a feed and you can
follow people and nobody used it and
then he built a Google group and nobody
used that either and then finally we're
like screw it we're this none of this
just freaking email them the data and
that was Angel list now I will end with
some reflections
Peter Thiel argues that to build a
profitable business you have to deliver
something unique and valuable to a group
of people now let's adapt this idea to a
passage from the book The Almanac of
Navara vacant which I think adds some
insightful nuances to this concept you
can go on the internet and you can find
your audience and you can build a
business and create a product and build
wealth and make people happy just
uniquely expressing yourself through the
internet the internet enables any Niche
interest as long as you're the best
person added to scale out and the great
news is because every human is different
everyone is the best at something being
themselves so you can deliver something
unique just by being yourself and then
if I sufficiently cited group of people
on the internet resonates with your
content or find your products useful you
can build a profitable business and even
better a profitable business that is
also aligned with your ideas and care
director and as you keep exploring your
curiosity that group of people will
naturally expand to a bigger group
something that is really unique and
valuable about being a content creator
is that the product and the distribution
are essentially the same thing so if
you're a content creator by default you
build a business in a parallel way you
build a product and the distribution at
the same time as Alex Ramos is said in a
conversation with the famous YouTuber
unspeakable it is one of the unique
things about the media business how you
Market the product is also how you
fulfill it besides there is no need for
external financing given the super tiny
upfront Investments and costs involving
the content creation business model and
in most cases it's not even necessary to
have a team of people
another cool thing is that once you get
some traction you immediately get the
feedback from the viewers and
subscribers so you can optimize your
content and products much more based on
what people actually want rather than
your intuition about what they want as
Paul Graham wrote on his book hackers
and Painters you want to keep the time
to Market as short as possible in order
to eventually come up with something
that people will actually want
and if you want to become a content
creator on YouTube you might want to
check out my services and free courses
I'll link it down in the description if
you found ideas of Peter Thiel Nasim
telev Navarre vacant and sahila India
interesting and you want to learn more I
recommend you to check out short form
where you can find super insightful
study guides from all of their books as
well as hundreds of other interesting
books but if you want to go deep into
their wisdom and invest the time then I
would definitely read their full books
Shuffle has made me smarter in many
areas of my life and I use it to quickly
discover interesting ideas from hundreds
of books and to revisit the main ideas
of books that I have already read the
cost is equivalent to the price of one
book a month and you can use my
affiliate link shortform.com picking
nuggets to get a five day free trial and
a 20 discount on the annual subscription